kind of give you some perspective women
modern women find 80 percent of men as
unattractive and so on dating apps which
people will argue that maybe people on
dating apps aren't looking for something
serious but that's the number one way
people meet women only swipe right five
percent of the time up to 20 on the high
end in certain studies so women are all
sleeping with the same guys so for guys
that are in that percentage it's like
they just have an abundance of girls
throwing themselves at them and then the
women will come back later and say men
are trash that's who who we need to have
a speed dating thing me and you know
yeah I have we need to set up a speed
dating or even a quoting thing when we
show them how to do it properly and give
them questions to ask you know speed
dating but we provide the questions we
look at look at you you're we're helping
me open wife school right yes things
turn modern women into wives you need to
try we need to do it we need to do we
don't want to be saved no they do I
think some do you know what right
is right I'm not saying that is wrong
but why does it always boil down to
women
okay no don't say no because you see
what Nathan said I like you Nathan by
the way I appreciate girl but what made
me feel like you're not scared you're
more like scared to be stuck in one
because there's so many options out
there because you keep dipping your
cookie into the jars different jars of
different sources so but here's here so
I think sorry the reason why you don't
want to come in I feel like the way you
explain to me to one jar is because
you're my ah because you saw the other
jar you saw the other thing you're like
it might taste you said too many options
that's what you said earlier
let me explain it to you so women leave
women divorce men 70 to 80 percent of
the time I I would argue in
relationships it's probably similar men
aren't leaving women are so to a guy's
point of view he's going to commit to
this girl and what does he get he
doesn't get Purity anymore you know
these These Hoes you know he doesn't he
doesn't get youth anymore so he doesn't
get either of those things a lot of
times she already has a kid so so he's
not fulfilling his mating strategy on
top of that even if he does find a good
woman that maybe has the qualities he's
looking for she was going to want him to
marry her right and what does he get out
of that oh she can leave and take half
and take my kids and she's paid to take
my kids away from me she she gets more
money if she takes my children and so
from the men's point of view they're
just kind of like effort because like
women aren't wives nowadays
and what do they get out of it like men
are logical they're logical people and
so they're thinking does the benefit
outweigh the cost and like I just think
as women we have to look at ourselves
and say the benefits we bring nowadays
don't outweigh the cost for most men
you know for the for the sake of
argument and finally it's about my turn
to you know help the boys out I'll tell
you something boys do you know the best
way for you to deal with a modern woman
be stush
stush means be a bit more stuck up about
yourself because actually girls don't
like rejection and when we reject one
she wants you more because it's a
challenge at that moment you've got the
power if you want her you want to
maneuver and check while she's on and
you want to get her in your in your
books but okay
listen to this listen to this from the
men's point of view so I have to play a
bunch of games with these women in order
to get to them to to commit to me why do
it at all
because because why is it worth it yeah
it's like what what is the benefit to
the men like what genuinely who who in
here has a cookbook maybe maybe you need
a cookbook what I do
are you ask me no my point is none of us
in here are can be considered
traditional women and back then an
average guy could get a traditional
woman and now what does he get he gets a
boss [ __ ] a boss babe a girl that's
been ran through he gets an ex-ho he
gets a born-again virgin like this is as
as women this is what what do we get we
still get protection and provisioning
are you sure and I mean
I mean okay okay but here's here's the
thing the average salary could cover an
apartment
and but the thing is like women we want
this lifestyle that's not even realistic
nowadays like we want men that make more
than we do and we want them to pay all
of the bills but it's like we work we
all have our nails done we have
um we get our hair dyed we have makeup
we have all of this stuff that costs
money because we want this lifestyle and
I've had girls come on my show and I say
would you would you date an average guy
for a companionship but you would have
to go down in lifestyle and they say no
we're addicted to Lifestyle
I would add from a male perspective what
what I find and I think that this is why
most guys don't bother and this is you
know why I I you know for me it's the
biggest kind of consumer of my energy
when it comes to dating in this whole
game is that everyone every all modern
women want my time and attention to them
when I go to a club there's 10 hot girls
who think I'm gonna get their number
talk to them for three months take them
out until they eventually decide to you
know we can do this or that or whatever
and it's it's just non-stop and they all
they all think they all think I have all
the time in the world and that they're
also special and interesting and that
they all deserve the red carpet
treatment and these women do nothing for
me they do absolutely nothing they come
barely hold a conversation they can't
start a conversation they've got no Day
ideas they don't even know how to be
feminine from they're saying that they
think wearing a tight skirt is feminine
you can stand around and guys would just
throw themselves at you which is which
is kind of like that's that's why which
is what they do and that's why I said
when was the last time a girl planned a
day for you oh my God like like plans
like a planned a whole day got you a
really a thoughtful gift that had
nothing to do with her nothing she
wanted I'm glad you asked that question
I don't remember the last time they
didn't do it but they talk about
equality a lot you guys but you're
generalizing a lot like even even if it
was just making fact that maybe liked
you or got feelings or whatever did any
of them like try to compete for you hell
no yeah
because it's an ego thing because girls
won't put aside their ego
Queens they're all boss [ __ ] no she's
got a point for once I'll agree with her
she does have a point girls do you know
what stop being so annoying if you have
if you want to see the guy ask him can I
see you if you want to go on a date with
him and you invite him make sure that
you did the invitation be polite have
manners and you're the one that is the
host there for you to patent the thing
stop always waiting for the guy to make
the first move I get the Impressions
you can't turn around and say that the
men want feminine women so how can a
woman go up to a man and say I'm gonna
take you out well also
I think that you're an amazing guy you
are sick I'm gonna shoot my shoes
so so devil's advocate here I I'm not I
wouldn't probably approach it like that
but like back in the day didn't women
drop the handkerchief
right right women drop the handkerchief
but that's what that you see the thing
is right is that years ago you dropped a
handkerchief and the man showed you was
interested you didn't drop your knickers
and that's the difference drop in a
handkerchief is totally different from
dropping your knickers
so you used to walk along in the old
days they used to drop a hat you know
you walk along and you drop a hanky just
to see whether or not the man was
interested
but now the women are dropping their
knickers to see whether the man's
interest no I don't think that's an
issue they're not dropping their
knickers because like a third of men as
virgins but they're dropping their
knickers more than we drop hankies no my
my my as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible